Hey David, there was recently a controversy
about Michael Bloomberg being called an oligarch.
Do you believe Michael Bloomberg is an oligarch?
So what is an oligarch generally defined?
An oligarch is a rich business leader with
a lot of political influence.
Now by that definition, of course, Michael
Bloomberg is an oligarch in the United States.
The term is more commonly used in Russia and
there's a sort of pejorative sense to the
word, but that's okay. We'll still use it
and, and, and use it for our analysis here.
If you have money to buy your way to 10% support
in a democratic primary, jumping in very,
very late, you are an oligarch in some sense.
And Michael Bloomberg is, he's still better
than Trump, but in this strict definition,
he is absolutely an oligarch. Now, we have
to recognize that the circumstances for oligarchs
in the United States are very different than
they are in places like Russia and Ukraine
were oligarchs have a degree of control there
that they simply do not have here individual
rich dudes with private armies in Russia and
Ukraine. That is different. And I know people
will say, well, the president gets these mercenaries.
I get it, but we are not talking about the
same thing. Bloomberg is an oligarch in that
he can use his vast wealth to buy his way
into the election, but he still needs to successfully
deploy the money to convince voters to support
him. Otherwise he won't get a single delegate.
He can't simply buy his way into office in
the same way that a Russian Petro billionaire,
Ken, you can buy your way into an ambassadorship
and we see it done quite, quite, quite often.
Um, a lot of the difference is really a difference
of degree, right? The level of corruption,
the U S is hugely corrupt in many ways, but
it is not nearly as corrupt as Russia is in
this sense. So I, you know, we've talked before,
why are they called oligarchs in Russia and
just billionaires in the United States? And
that's a fair question. But there is a difference
and it's not just Russia and Ukraine.
The term oligarch is less used in some African
nations, but it would certainly apply there
as well. Uh, in some of the Islamic theocracies
of the middle East. The term oligarch is not
used that frequently, but it would also apply
in a way that it simply does it in the United
States. But for the standards of the United
States for the level of corruption we have,
which is corrupt, but it's not what exists
in other countries. The U S a you can actually
look at the corruption rankings and see where
we are. Uh, Michael Bloomberg is an oligarch
by any reasonable American interpretation
of the term, but we still have a very different
situation here than we do in many other countries.
The people who went crazy when Michael Bloomberg
was called an oligarch, I think it was on
MSNBC or whatever, come on. The guy is essentially
an oligarch, although that just means something
different here than it means in, for example,
Ukraine or Georgia or the country
or Russia.